hi guys scifi recapped here before we
start warning spoilers ahead today i'm
going to explain a 2021 american
satirical science fiction movie called
don't look up
the movie begins with kate dibioski a
phd candidate who currently works at a
space station after setting up a device
she spots what looks like a comet
hurtling toward earth on the screen
shocked with what she has discovered she
invites her co-worker professor randall
mindy and other colleagues to celebrate
mindy decides to name the comment after
her name comet dibioski the professor is
amazed with the discovery and does some
calculation to measure the distance
between the comet and earth
however based on the calculation result
he realizes that the comet is far more
dangerous than they expected and tells
the others to go home except kate the
next day they call dr calder
representative of kennedy space center
and dr teddy oglethorpe head of
planetary defense coordination office
revealing to them that the comets is
huge sized around 5-10 kilometers wide
and is going to hit the earth in 6
months and 14 days
mindy is frightened by the fact that the
earth is going to be destroyed in less
than a year
after that they travel to the white
house where they are welcomed by dr
oglethorpe and general themes
while waiting the general offers them a
snack and a water which he charges them
for twenty dollars not a very reasonable
price for a snack
later that night kate discovers that all
snacks provided in the white house are
free they are supposed to inform the
president about the upcoming catastrophe
event but after waiting for seven hours
jason chief of staff suddenly comes out
from the room and tells them that the
meeting is not gonna happen tonight at
hotel kate calls her boyfriend phillip
and tries to tell him about getting
herself stranded in the white house for
seven hours but he doesn't seem to care
about it and fills her with his work
problems which she is not interested in
realizing that kate is not very
responsive he brings up her issue with
his mom and starts a fight with her on
the other side professor mindy calls his
wife june and his two grown-up sons
telling them his finding at work the
next day they returned to the white
house where mindy and kate explained the
situation to president janie orlean and
jason
despite them playing up the major
imminent threat by telling them that the
comment is a planet killer the white
house representatives don't seem to care
much for it and don't think of it as a
big threat since their calculation does
not have a 100 certainty even though it
is at 99.78
the president even doubts their
credentials as a scientist dr oglethorpe
suggests an immediate strategy to
deflect and change the orbit of the
comet so it doesn't collide with earth
by using drones that are equipped with
nukes but it seems that the president
cannot fulfill that request since
political matters come first
she concludes the meeting by saying they
should just sit tight tonight and assess
which makes kate and mindy furious
meanwhile in the silicon valley there is
a presentation by a tech company called
bash cellular the ceo peter eicherwell
introduces their newest product leaf
which can detect how its user is feeling
and provides them with the right
contents to cheer them up after the
event he is shown a picture of the comet
the scientists then plan to leak his
confidential information to the press
the new york herald representatives
agree to make an article about the
comment since the calculations are
credible they are also invited to a
popular show hosted by bree and jack
called the daily rip mindy tries so hard
to fight his public speaking anxiety
before their turn pop star riley bina
comes first to talk about her breakup
with fellow musician dj cello
the show even provides them a live chat
where the ex-couple reconcile and riley
randomly accepts cello's marriage
proposal
after that mindy and kate go on air
while dr oglethorpe watches from home
they explain that the comment could
damage the entire planet but the hosts
don't take it seriously which makes kate
lose her temper and start screaming that
they are all going to die
she then walks out from the studio while
mindy maintains his composure after the
show brie invites mindy to get a drink
together
following her exaggerated expression and
bold statement on the show kate
eventually becomes a meme on the
internet while mindy becomes popular
because of his calm looks he is
disappointed since no one is terrified
with the upcoming disastrous event
meanwhile kate's boyfriend deliberately
posts an article about him sleeping with
kate and implicitly states that he wants
to break up with her
later that night tv news reports that
presidents orleans nude pictures have
been leaked which will damage her
popularity for the next presidential
election
the next day mindy kate and dr
oglethorpe are arrested at different
locations by fbi agents and are brought
to the white house to meet with orlean
it is then revealed that she wants to
use this comet issue to divert public
attention away from the scandal jason
delivers a presidential apology and
states that they agree to proceed with
oglethorpe strategy earlier to deflect
the comet's route to regain trust from
the american people orlian is going to
make a presidential statement the
following day about the comet collision
with earth telling the citizens that
nasa and the military army will launch a
preemptive strike to blow the comet off
its course
since the country always gotta have a
hero she assigns patriot benedict drast
to be in charge of the mission the
scientists are so relieved with the
decision
since the statement the news of the
comment has become a highlight and mindy
also becomes famous because of his
charming face surprisingly he also hooks
up with brie the host at the daily rip
since he becomes a recurring guest on
the show
she reveals to mindy that she has slept
with two former presidents
it is the launch day and the nation
watches as benedict and his team launch
into space while the scientists and the
president watch from the white house
a few moments later peter who turns out
to be the donor for the mission shows up
at the room and urges to speak with
orlean privately
not long after the launching benedict
and his team appear to turn around and
begin pulling back to earth suddenly
aborting the mission which makes
everyone confused the scientists who
have no idea what just happened are
locked in a room while questioning the
president's decision to call off the
mission
suddenly jason approaches them and
assigns mindy as chief science advisor
for the white house at the emergency
meeting peter reveals that the comet
contains an abundant amount of the most
valuable minerals in earth which are now
being used in the manufacture of phones
and computers
since the minerals are running short and
most of these mineral mines are now
managed by china this comment will be an
astonishing opportunity for the state's
economy if they somehow manage to
harvest the minerals from there
mindy disagrees with the idea but the
ceo assures him that the mining
procedure will be extremely safe to
earth since the comet will be crushed
into 30 smaller meteoroids which will
bring less harm while being steered and
decelerated by with the latest
technologies developed by the company
into the ocean
u.s navy ships will be waiting at the
ocean and will be ready to claim the
debris
that night mindy shares the comet mining
idea to his colleagues who think that it
will never work
mindy seems to believe the ceo's plan
and attempts to convince kate and dr
oglethorpe that there is still a hope
kate disagrees yelling at him that it is
a complete disaster which attracts
people in the bar she loses control and
decides to spill the information to
everyone there causing chaos at the bar
because of that they have to tie her up
and the white house wants her off the
grid
dr oglethorpe walks away as he is also
disappointed with mindy's decision to
take sides with the government after
signing an agreement with fbi agents
kate returns home only to discover that
her parents are also supporting peter's
plan since the comet will provide jobs
for them
meanwhile mindy is seen in the
advertisement encouraging people not to
fear about the upcoming comment june
later confronts mindy and brie in his
room surprisingly brie doesn't feel
remorse at all for screwing other's
husband disappointed she demonstrates
how to take care of mindy tabri by
throwing all of his numerous medications
at him after that she walks away
on the other side kate now works as a
cashier at a supermarket where she meets
an anti-government activist named ewell
he invites her to come over to the
playground
later that night she attends the party
or later she hooks up with yule
meanwhile mindy is introduced to the
bash drone that peter claims will be a
mankind savior he doubts the readiness
of the device but peter is offended with
that and convinces him that all devices
created by bash will never disappoint in
a harsh way
at the daily rip mindy suddenly becomes
enraged and yells at the camera that
people should be worried since a giant
comet as big as mount everest is going
to hit the earth he finally speaks up
and expresses his fear toward the
catastrophe accusing the president that
she has been lying all the time
after the show he gets a bag on his head
like kate was and brie breaks things off
with him while spending her quality time
with her new boyfriend kate spots the
comment entering the earth's atmosphere
mindy realizes it as well and
immediately calls his colleague he
reconciles with her and they meet up
broadcasting the event all around the
world since that two sides are formed
the first one is don't look up that is
initiated by the president and her
supporters to oppose mindy's warning and
the other one is the just look up side
where the people already accept the
reality mindy and kate conduct a concert
where they tell people that there is no
safe way to bring the comet to earth and
it needs to be destroyed they also
invite riley bina to perform a song that
encourages people to look up the next
day dr oglethorpe is informed that the
president and bash have cut russia india
and china out of the rights for the
minerals the countries then decide to
deflect the comet on their own but a
massive explosion is detected at the
russian launch complex
that means if the bash mission fails the
earth will be destroyed clueless and
hopeless mindy decides to bring kate and
her new boyfriend to go grocery shopping
acting like nothing is going to happen
he returns home and reconciles with his
wife dr oglethorpe also shows up at
mindy's house to join the party they
then have a family dinner together and
don't care anymore whether the bash
mission is successful or not
it's the d-day of the bash comet mining
mission people around the world are
watching from home some of them are
praying while the super advanced drones
called bead are launched toward the
comet however several beads failed to
launch peter ensures the others that it
is still within the margin of air and
everything is fine
upon reaching the comet the beads begin
to falter or get destroyed due to the
malfunction which makes janie and peter
realize their efforts are futile
until now the comment is still intact
and the rich including the president and
peter realize that it is time for them
to run away from earth orlean then calls
mindy apologizing for not trusting him
earlier
she then offers him and his wife to join
her in an expedition to the nearest
earth-like planet he rejects the offer
and chooses to stay with his loved ones
unfortunately jason is left behind in
the control room
they then pray to god as the comet
eventually hits the ground and slowly
destroys the whole earth into pieces
more than 22 000 years later peter
orlion and the other survivors in the
pods arrive nude at an earth-like planet
which is inhabited by weird creatures
and they begin to eat the humans alive
meanwhile jason somehow survives from
the disaster and now lives alone on the
earth
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching